[Music]
you know the goal is the more you get up
and start doing projects
uh the healthier you will be if you
master the basics then you become
advanced a lot of times people want to
skip to the ninja stuff well guess what
ninja stuff is nothing but mastering the
basics some skills are boring so my job
really is okay break it down make it as
simple as possible and then make it
entertaining and informative at the same
time your parents didn't teach you this
are you kidding me
and there he is what's up how you doing
bud clint emerson the house he's the
author of a new book called the rugged
life he's a new york times best-selling
author a retired navy seal and he's
joining us live today how you doing man
good so um in going through your book i
would say reading your book but there's
so many pictures in it that it's it's so
much more of a instructional guide than
a typical you know book book that that
when i saw it um i am probably the least
handy person that i know
so i was i was nervous to get into it
like oh my gosh what's clint gonna
there's the cover behind him on the wall
what's gonna what's what's it gonna dive
me into when i sold my company i built
the 5000 foot like square foot giant
beautiful home and sold it because it
was too much maintenance and work that i
didn't want to do so i'm like heavy on
the convenient side
uh moved into a condo for the next 12
years and then like two months ago just
got this place a brand new house that
now your book is going to be helpful for
me to get all the skills again
um how much of the book would you say is
actually about the skill development to
learn versus just the mindset of hey i
can i can be self-reliant yeah it's a
combination of both but mindset of
course is
is priority no matter what it is you're
doing in life right so
i would say with rugged life type skills
which is all about self-reliance and
starting to do things
your step yourself instead of waiting on
others or hiring others or uh you know
worst case scenario it's
all the skills are back-up plans they're
options so that when you have the next
crisis in your life at least you've got
the skills just do it yourself right so
the mental aspect is number one you've
gotta say yes i'm gonna start becoming
more self-reliant number two you gotta
decide okay well what
area in your lifestyle do you want to
start trying to tackle so if you're
mechanically income inclined or you grew
up like me where my dad was like go get
the 5 8 wrench like okay and you're
digging through a drawer looking for the
5 8 wrench
then maybe that's the path you go
because that's how you grew up but what
i'm finding out is there's a lot of
adults
that didn't have parents
that was tasking them with you know
different skills or teaching them
different skills i kind of this book
even though it's titled the rugged life
i also kind of say it's like
the the dad skills that have been
forgotten right
and it's giving it's kind of bringing
all that back to the forefront in light
of a pandemic and light of you know a
downward economy and light of
you know
global issues you know you name it it
seems like every day there's something
new in the news but um if you want to
insulate yourself from all the bull out
there a great way to start is just
becoming more self-reliant that way the
world doesn't affect you
what i love about it is it covers some
very basic things to start with so it's
like how to build a fire put a newspaper
in kindling in a lock right
yeah like different types of nails but
then all the way up to like hey okay
we're going to go hunting now are you
going to raise pigs or how to find your
way in the dark and find where true
north is it's like you're teaching
people a whole bunch of skills and it's
all
not all but a lot of picture-based so
it's easy to pick up yeah for for me the
thing is
so i value convenience so a lot of a lot
of typical rugged stuff i i might have
dismissed but what i what i value over
convenience is health
and so i'm wondering how some of these
might be able to be reframed towards
health so here's an example you have one
about them
how to cut wood with an axe right right
and i got an axe behind me this is a
gift from from ed my lead and uh andy
for silva i've never used it just kind
of sits there i don't know if i'm if i
should use it but we had this tree fall
down uh this giant tree fell down after
a storm and my wife's like oh we should
cut that up and turn that into firewood
it's like i don't want to cut that up
you know it's like just
get rid of it and go buy some firewood
or give it to the neighbor or something
but then in the book you said uh the
quote was hand chopping wood is nature's
gym
yeah
yeah and like huh as soon as it reframes
the health it's like
i should do that so maybe i should go
buy an axe and make that happen
uh what are the i think there's so many
different ways that you could take this
whether it's just learning the skills in
cases of crisis whether you want to live
off grid because you're worried about
big brother whether it's like uh
environmental reasons collecting your
own rain water kind of stuff
if you're defaulting to health like me
where are some of the things where okay
it may not be as convenient to do but it
can really improve your health
oh there's a bunch um you know i like i
like the fact that you're using the word
convenient right because
the rugged life is not convenient but it
is far more satisfactory and and
gratifying when you do it yourself and
you earned it you know and you didn't
just go buy it
um and another thing i just want to
point out is it doesn't mean you have to
go throw your phone away and technology
away right it's it's the modern guide to
self-reliance so it's leveraging what
you've got in order to use it to start
doing stuff yourself but i would say
you know in be your own hunter you know
people have mixed issues and you know
thoughts when it comes to hunting but i
talk about you know the big reasons why
you should know how to do it and one
it's getting you outside getting you in
nature which is a healthy thing to do
two it's getting you out away and into
the rural environments where all of a
sudden
you're using your five you know senses
to really take in and learn something
new
not just what's going on around you but
yourself right
and then hunting your own food is
is an entirely new game in itself right
you're going after whatever game it is
that you want but
you know where that animal came from
when you go to the grocery store you
have no idea okay so you know where the
animal came from you knew who prepped it
who cooked it and then of course then
you eat it so
it there's a lot there's a lot to that
but there are so many health benefits to
that it's uh
it's a long long list of you know mainly
because it's organic you know that that
animal
you know lived off the land and wasn't
fed a bunch of stuff and
you know wasn't given a bunch of
steroids or you know whatever it is that
you know a lot of your uh your big
processing plants are doing these days
when you go hunting you know none of
that's taking place right same with
farming be your own farmer as a chapter
maybe you're a vegetarian you know and
maybe you live in new york you can grow
a lot of stuff right there on your
windowsill you know you don't have to go
out and buy land and start planting
crops
i'm trying to provide all these great
kind of self-reliant projects
that you can get up off your couch and
do right now and almost everything
connects to health because
you're getting up and you're doing
something
you know so it's real easy to go amazon
or you know ubereats or uber lyft or
uber uber uber uh you know those are all
great convenient ways when you might not
have a refrigerator full of food but
you know the goal is the more you get up
and start doing projects
uh the healthier you will be
and not to mention if you're a family
person you've got kids
i mean
no better way to live no better example
to set
than doing it yourself and teaching your
kids along the way so that they grow up
with some skills you know my grand my
granddad he's like you know he's a world
war ii guy
you know depre you know great depression
kid
you know so you're talking every time i
went to his house he was always doing
something he was never just sitting
around you know even at in his older
ages you know so it's like
you know that's where i learned like you
know and i reflect on the most is
man we don't do that anymore you know
and so
hopefully the book gives people projects
that not only give them a backup plan or
an option when the primary options go
down
but it gets gets you up moving again and
doing things with your family
yeah and you know back to convenience it
may even be more convenient like if i'm
if the wood's already there
instead of doing a workout i could just
chop it and i get my exercise in at the
same time right like yeah why why go and
buy the weights and start lifting the
weights if i can just chop the tree in
the backyard
um have you thought about taking people
on retreats or doing you know like the
rugged life boot camp and guiding people
through some of these activities it's
funny you mentioned that i'm gonna have
what you know my brand is kind of more
of the nomad philosophy you know just
get out be
being self-reliant means confidence in
yourself right
so it's kind of a nomad mindset and
so i was going to have uh start offering
a nomad challenge right so it's it's a
challenge but you get to learn along the
way but for the most part you're
you're doing it on your own with me
being your guide but everything you're
doing yourself right so
that's that's actually coming it's kind
of funny i just drafted out the outline
the plan and here you are asking the
question which is
you know very coincidental
i love it dude the nomad challenge and
even especially for some of the beginner
stuff what i love about you is you can
go hardcore off the deep end like deep
dive with people on topics but you can
also make it simple for people who
are just getting started on the plan
like i don't know how to build a fire so
here's how you take the steps or like
the 10 types of nails that you can use
and how to find a stud on the wall it's
like very very basic stuff um
but again people might be too
embarrassed to admit that they don't
know that so that here's the book to be
able to go through and read it yeah well
i always connect that to bad parenting
your parents didn't teach you this are
you kidding me but uh but yeah it's it's
really hey let's bring the basics back
if there was one thing i learned in the
seal teams more than anything else
is that if you master the basics then
you become
advanced right and you can apply that to
everything just master the basics which
is a lot a lot of times people want to
skip to the ninja stuff well guess what
ninja stuff is nothing but the mastering
the basics and uh and that applies to
whether it's rugged life or even my all
my books are illustrated so the 100
deadly skill series is all about the
same kind of thing self-reliance
saving yourself and whether it's a
crisis that seconds minutes or days
you know you've got to know how to kind
of take care of yourself and rugged life
is more of a lifestyle you know that's
why i broke the chapters out the way i
did that you know be your own hunter be
your own fisherman be your own be your
own be your own
and um and hopefully if you just take in
a little bit of it you'll be better for
it in the long run you know just it's
always just in case you know
you talk about backup plans and how some
of these skills could be really helpful
and you kind of knowing the skills when
your friends don't could be really
helpful not just for you but for your
whole community and neighborhood yeah
for people who
you know if somebody's off in the middle
of nowhere then they need to have a lot
you know maybe a different backup plan
you talk about being your own like radio
transmitter operator and all these
things but for people who live in the
city
or sub suburbs what do you think are the
the more realistic backup plan scenarios
that you actually see coming that people
are not paying enough attention to
well i think the pandemic really
highlighted any everybody's
inability to kind of
care and feed for themselves right
so i think having
the backup or contingency plan as it
relates to water you know i talk about
that book and give you know i mean
probably my favorite part was water
containment you know and i put in a very
simple math equation in there that i
thought it blew me away right one inch
of rain
that falls onto a thousand square foot
roof
if you were to collect that into the
gutters and into barrels
that would be one inch of rain thousand
square foot roof
is equivalent to 600 plus gallons of
free water right
so if you just
set up the system which is really easy
you know using gutters you can throw
pantyhose over your gutters
and
you know that'll filter out bird poop
and leaves and dirt
then you've got free clean water to
start with and of course you'd want to
filter it further but
you've got these sources of water right
and you know not toilet paper water
water is the more important thing than
toilet paper and then next to that is
food right so
you know i would say
having a basic garden
or you know if you have got a backyard
you can i mean a backyard you can do
everything most people just don't think
about it but you can grow
enough food
uh you know all year round with a small
backyard you can do vertical gardens
these days if you live in an apartment
you know and you don't have the space
you can do a vertical garden in the
corner of your apartment
um i put in i talk about one in there
that
is using spare tires let's say you want
a garden on a budget right you can put a
spare tire you can collect them for free
from your local you know tire dealer or
you know like a discount tire co
one tire
throw in dirt
take up a potato chop it up spread it
out into the dirt you know basically
burying it right once you see green
sprout you throw another tire you fill
it with dirt you break you know take
another potato into that section once
you see green again and you just keep
doing that you can stack it six tires
high which is about six feet tall full
of dirt and that'll be hundreds of
potatoes in the corner of your apartment
right now of course you gotta have some
sunlight right and you gotta do some
watering but for the most part you can
do vertical gardens anywhere
and have a source of food growing all
the time whether you use it or not you
know it's kind of
is not really the point it's a backup
plan the irish lived off potatoes for
freaking what hundreds of years
so you know it's a
it's not a bad
process or a bad piece to add to your
lifestyle you know it's not a big deal
once you start you actually find
yourself becoming pretty proud of
yourself that you oh i did that you know
for the water collection is it so when i
saw that said okay i wonder what my
water i don't know my monthly water bill
is it's not really like that important
number to bring down for me yeah is it
is it is it just the backup plan then
besides the cost savings or is is there
another benefit to having your own water
well you know so that goes back to we
hear on grid we hear off grid
but my big thing is what if there's no
grid right i live in texas and our
entire grid went down two winners ago
no
you know having
whether it's water whether it's food
whatever it is
if you can resource it yourself
then you're gonna be better for it right
and so that's that's that's really
number one is there cost benefit sure of
course you know um water isn't exactly
expensive
even if you stock up on bottled water
that's great too but
um but there's there's ways to collect
it and when you do the collection piece
the beauty of that is
you're collecting it for the family
you're collecting it for let's say your
garden you're collecting it for your
animals
so
that collected water goes a long way and
now it becomes
you know imagine if you had animals a
garden and the family
now you're really saving some money
i love it um there's some fun hacks that
you've talked about like if you want to
raise chickens say that they're a
therapy animal
yeah
for you are there other other hacks that
you've come across and noticed more for
getting around
getting around the rules that people are
trying to force you how to live yeah so
that one you know i brought up because
of hoas a lot of people live in these
pre-planned developments and you know
homeowner associations will say no no no
you can't have chickens
but if you go and register them as you
know whether it's mental health or
service pets or whatever
um then you show them that piece of
paper they can't do anything at that
point right now i've got friends that
have done it with chickens they've done
it with their goats
you can get away with
declaring any animal really a service
animal and all of a sudden hoa and law
enforcement everybody will just leave
you alone right
so that's one i mean
i mean we talked about the water hack i
mean it's it's free and it's there and
it's everywhere but you just don't think
about it um
other hacks i think i think is just
coconut oil holy crap i mean you can
take coconut oil and you know besides
the sexual inner windows that come with
that it's more about you know you could
it is the main ingredient to shampoo
conditioner
pomade so i've got the whole be your own
homemaker right i mean
and if you've got coconut oil you can
pretty much do everything with that i
mean it's just amazing and it's usually
the one thing that's there's usually a
jar of it sitting in everybody's
cupboard around the country
um and if you just read that chapter i
mean you'll have a ton of projects that
save you money it's super easy uh and
you know where it came from which is key
these days
when i when i saw that part about the
chicken as a therapy animal i sent it to
my friend mark because he he lives in
the city one and like his goal is to
move the suburbs or like beyond the
suburbs just to raise chickens because
he can't do it where he's at like mark
watch this you know you have the messy
therapy animals you get to go now
yeah it's all about simplicity you know
keep it simple
so how do you go from you know retire
from the navy seals
to then deciding to write these life
hack books and trying to bring maybe
some of the maybe not quite that level
of mental toughness but some of it and
that desire to bring that to america and
the world
you know i um it's an interesting story
it may be too long but i'll give you the
short version um
you know i had no intentions of writing
books i was actually one of those guys
sitting at my seal team
and you know
the news playing in the background and
then there's some talking head navy seal
who just wrote a book and i was that guy
sitting there going those
sellouts
and so you know it's it's become a joke
now you know like if you're a seal then
you must have a book
um
but i had i had a buddy of mine um
naval academy grad he was an officer
doing vietnam so he was an older guy
very successful said hey clint you want
to write a book together and i was kind
of like nah not really and then he
started kind of throwing these ideas of
these illustrated manuals
um
that would provide skills to people and
you could just you know do volumes
because people always need to know how
to do stuff right
and so i was like huh that's kind of a
different approach right it's not a an
autobiography it's not uh
you know
some team building leadership crap that
every other seal has already written
it was it's like
real stuff tangible and that's what i
kind of like right
and uh and so we we started to put
together 100 deadly skills
um
and then because he's an older guy he
blew his back out needed to have surgery
and after we signed the contract with
simon schuster he calls me goes yeah
blew my back out you're on your own i
was like what
because remember this is a guy who's
already published like 40 books and
here's this is my first time i'm like i
don't know what i'm doing yeah you'll
figure it out
and that was it i was on my own and
put 100 daily skills together and you
know it ended up on the new york times
list for uh like eight months straight
who would have thought that a little
survival book would uh
would hit that list because they're very
subjective and uh
and anyway we've kind of been going ever
since and what i love about it is it's
uh it's not a book that you read cover
to cover it's it's really to choose your
own adventures like what do you want to
learn what do you want to get better at
and go to that section of the book as
opposed to having to complete it
you know page at a time yeah and that's
that's a little bit of the military in
me coming out in the version of a book
like i always loved fm the field manuals
fm manuals that we would get while in in
the military issued to us
um because one i like the fact that they
didn't just write
garbage in there just to create more
pages to create a thicker book right
um you they gave you just the facts and
it usually had some cool illustration of
an army soldier doing something right
and so that was my inspiration i was
like man i love those fm manuals i love
the fact that they don't have any extra
rhetoric or bull it was just here's how
you do it right that's all you need to
know this is how you do this
um and so all my books i've i've tried
my best
to just give you exactly what you need
to know without all the fluff and um
yeah so that's that's you you identified
something that's really important to me
when i build these things
it's kind of like when i was in the boy
scouts we had these little guides that
were similar a lot of pictures how to
start a fire how to get a flame going um
or people were in scouts uh even just
think of the airplane manuals that the
little pictures of like how to put your
face mask on that you see in the back
it's that's basically the whole book and
now he clint has a lot more that he
wrote in there but but it's very visual
so it's really easy to see because some
of the things you talk about
i would imagine it's really hard to just
describe as opposed to being able to see
the picture to get it
right yeah i find too the second part to
my job not only providing skills but
how do you do it in a very digestible
way right how do you do it in an
entertaining way you know because some
skills are boring so my job really is
okay break it down make it as simple as
possible and then make it entertaining
and informative at the same time so so
how are you enjoying this chapter i
guess no pun intended of your life of
doing content now
uh
i have my moments i'll be on i mean it's
uh
yeah i mean i i'm just like everybody
else there's days i wake up and i'm like
what the [ __ ] did i get myself into like
i feel like oh i need to post something
oh i need to do some kind of content and
then i'm like
then i just have these moments when i
don't want to do anything to be honest
with you so
i think that's shared across the board
but
the way i deal with it or the way i'm
you know try to make it enjoyable is
be original be yourself you know don't
hold back regardless of the criticism
regardless of all the you know third
parties that scrutinize that out of you
i just go
i'm just gonna be me and do whatever i
want and then the people that want to
buy it buy it the people that don't
don't you know you just kind of
once i once you kind of embrace that
then it's you know it's a little easier
but but i have my moments where you know
it's like
you know man i hope people like this man
i hope my book makes at least a list
right
you start to get that
once again it's that competitive
competitive spirit that's
that's in every seal it's in every
person really it's just you gotta some
people just have a harder time finding
it
um but i guess the hardest thing once
you're out of the navy is
how do i how do i like
make these things fun and
um
relatable
to everyone else without all the
military jargon and all that kind of
stuff you know but that's specific to
the books but the transition
the transition in itself is uh
is a day by day thing it's sometimes i
have easy days sometimes i have hard
days but it's ongoing i tell people all
the time nobody just transitions nobody
just pivots the pivot
has a pretty long timeline to it at
least for me right
i like every day it's you know
you know i just gotta talk out loud to
myself like okay go work out okay that's
done okay
go do something productive
you know other days i don't have to talk
to myself i just get up and go but
you know it's a balance right
well i love the humanity and i think
it's something that people might not
expect from a
retired navy seal you know you put your
time in
did it say hey he gets up and it's 4 a.m
every day and he's off and he's crushing
it and training and doing what he needs
to do so
uh great to hear the humanity as well um
well clint thank you for your time today
the everybody the book is called the
rugged life youtube will link it up in
the description below go check it out
the last book was a new york times
bestseller and uh sending you lots of
love and luck for the rugged life having
equal success man hey i appreciate your
time great hanging out with you and
thank you
to see my one-on-one with the iceman wim
hof check the video right there next to
me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there remember
deep breathing is able
is able to change the biochemistry
insight
deeper than ever thought possible